dans mon de la technologie on a beaucoup
parlé de l'année 2015 comme celle de
l'arrivée de la réalité virtuelle avec
la mise en marché prochaine des lunettes
des géants samsung sony ou encore oculus
mais assez arriver il faudra maintenant
compter avec un nouveau joueur
la réalité augmentée monsieur bonsoir
jean céline l'art quelle est la
différence entre la réalité virtuelle la
réalité augmentée où est la réalité
virtuelle mais ce sont tout simplement
des écrans qui nous isole de notre
environnement
les écrans qui sont très proches des
yeux la réalité augmentée c'est un peu
moins invasif ce sont des images qui se
superpose à ce qu'on voit
on pense tout de suite au fameux head up
d'esprit les rhodes qu'on retrouve dans
les avions de chasse et où l'information
qui est essentiel au pilote est
directement en face de ses yeux n'est
pas besoin de se baisser pour regarder
les informations essentielles c'est un
peu l'équivalent de la réalité pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en parle maintenant oui
parce que d'une part on appris à la fin
2014 que google avait investi un demi
milliard de dollars dans une start-up
floridienne magic ligue qui travaille
sur une réalité un type de réalité
augmentée où on diffuse des images
directement sur la rétine et plus
récemment on a vu que cette compagnie
l'avait déposé des brevets alors c'est
complètement c'est la science fiction
parce qu'en principe ce qu'ils proposent
dans leurs brevets c'est que vous
pourriez par exemple céline avec ses
lunettes leur regardez vos mains et vous
auriez vous y compte que vous retrouvez
d'habitude sur les tablettes dont pour
aller consulter vos textos aller sur
facebook et le ça paraît comme ça dans
vos dents dans votre environnement est
ce simplement c'est seulement vous qui
voyez seul assez fascinant il ya aussi
le géant microsoft la caf et une annonce
surprise la semaine dernière oui c'est
ça la suite de l' annonce du windows 10
dont 2 systèmes le système
d'exploitation on annonce est donc la
sortie de lunettes qui s'appelle léolo
lem ceux qui sont des lunettes de
réalité augmentée est ce qu'on peut y
voir absolument fascinant imaginer le
jeu minecraft sur les images on peut
voir au lieu de jouer à l'écran c'est
que notre salon au complet se transforme
en terrain de jeu c'est complètement
virtuel et des applications aussi pour
des manuels d'instruction par exemple on
pourrait éventuellement penser qu'on
montrait des meubles ikea avec des
manuels d'instruction à 3 10 devant nous
alors ça c'est peut-être une bonne
nouvelle pour les couples venir tuer ça
et en plus de ça c'est que l'ana
actuellement annoncé qu'il travaille
depuis cinq ans avec microsoft pour pour
créer un logiciel qui s'appelle insight
qui permet de recréer littéralement en
3d la planète mars alors des
scientifiques peuvent se promener sur
une reconstitution qui a été fait à
partir de photos envoyées par le son
curiosité alors on a enlevé ses lunettes
là et on se retrouve littéralement
entouré de la planète mentionné comme si
on y était et ce à deux ça ça pose la
question est ce qu'on peut est ce que ça
donne vraiment là le goût d'y aller ou
le besoin d'y aller une fois qu'on peut
recréer des environnements comme ça mais
littéralement autour de nous comme
journal et j'irai n'y a jamais rien
comme le terrain alors ça sort quand
pour le grand public cette technologie
là quand est ce que vous allez les avoir
moi j'aimerais le plus tôt possible il
ya pas de date mais qui est encore
annoncée mais retenez ce nom là en 2015
vous allez entendre parler de réalité
virtuelle et de réalité augmentée en du
monde qui était jusqu'ici seulement
réservé à des amateurs de choses plus ou
moins légales mais le ca va être dans
votre salon pour quelques centaines de
dollars
alors se préparer beaucoup font plaisir